so that's that's tapped into my family
my uncle's like a character in that [__]
his car got blown
[Music]
up welcome back everybody to another
Stellar episode of the careful boys and
today we are so privileged to have
silent Mike back in the wow oh wow it's
want to be a careful boy dude I've been
saying my prayers eating my vitamins you
want to see something show us the
receipt all right well I'm going to make
your ter a boy right now you're
absolutely not he's got to buy it it's
it's a oh [__] I'm ready dog oh you sh
I'm ready
[__] dog I thought the tattoo artist was
about careful boy shirts available
now here you go Mike dude are you
[__] serious did you just shave your
leg for no it's a long story my little
cousin waxed it but can you check if
that was an extra large cuz it looks
like a medium on you EXL it'll fit are
you sure I don't think so man I'll put
it on we'll do a a wet t-shirt contest
you look even bigger than last time dude
look even more SW look [__] giant
don't do it over that it's not going to
spit dude I think you need a
double I guess maybe what makes him look
even buffer it looks like a undershirt
on him so tell long story it's not that
long you show your face can in case they
just go where did that crunch come
from just
hear Shin story it's not that
interesting so I I haven't seen my
family in like uh 10 12 years I went
back for a couple funerals of course
that's the only time you see your
family I'm in like the middle gen so all
my cousins are like 50s and I'm the
youngest cousin and then their kids are
just below me right that's like me
they're like 15s 20s but they're at the
age where I can like be normal around
them I don't have to do baby [__] right
so I'm like taking them on an errand and
I don't know what they're doing they're
doing some gen Z stuff and I just go on
a huge rant about how [__] soft they
are I'm just like you guys are so
[__] soft nowadays and I'm just one's
like 25 fun to hang out with yeah I'm
the I'm the fun Uncle for sure we were
getting pizza you know the end result's
fun what what were they complaining
about that made you go you're you so
[__] so they got like a it wasn't even a
fender bender I think uh they were
driving in an SUV and I think a motorc
it probably was scary I think a
motorcycle hit them going pretty quick
and in Ohio I don't think you have to
wear a helmet so I think dude's head was
bleeding and [__] I think it was kind of
traumatic but you know suck it up dud
stop being soft stop being a [__] got
decapitated they were complaining that
someone got hurt and they were bothered
by it they were fine but they did get
hit they did see the bleeding so but but
but and they were joking halfway so I'm
like driving them to pizza and like oh
my God I think that's where it
happened and they were like half serious
half joking they're reminiscing about
the accident I believe so and either way
I just bitched at him so then I go back
to the house where everybody's there
right like six aunties cousins and and
their dad's like oh I was the Carl I was
like good man but like these kids are
soft and then the youngest cousin out of
nowhere she's like 17 so like oh yeah
what makes you so tough love it I said
what makes me tough I do I do hard [__]
all the time like I do hard [__] every
day she like she's like I bet you can't
get waxed I said I can get [__] waxed
so of course we go to CVS she gets the
Wax Kit she waack you had to go get it
bro she waxed my cousin's head which
probably hurt yeah family is crazy bro
my bro it's just like Italian Midwest
[__] we don't have nothing else you're
from the Midwest dude we ain't got [__]
waxing I wax my [__] I let people wax my
legs that's soft [__] what happened was
so what happened was I pulled my sock
down and you know she's on Tik Tok or
some [__] so her camera's up I pulled my
sock down thinking she do one of these
and I could wear high socks she warms
that [__] up and just slaps it mid chin
and I'm like all right well here we go
and then it really didn't hurt at one I
was like I Was preparing it to hurt and
look tough but it really didn't hurt
that much she's like it does hurt though
it didn't hurt really not really he's
tough yeah yeah I do hard [__] dog we
got our armpits waxed and it was
bleeding armpits a little different yeah
you try to do your man Parts you do like
the devil's Canali down there and that's
going to you mean the GU the connector
it's called The Devil's Canal or Highway
orever Canal the the pain is worth the
pleasure cuz afterwards when you get
licked it feels good your butthole eaten
out am men's Brazilian you guys got a
Brazilian nope but I should but I'm so
embarrassed that I think I'll pretend to
be gay when I'm in there yeah that makes
sense that makes you less embarrassed
that's an interesting perspective how
are you so embarrassed that you pretend
to be gay if I get my [__] waxed I
don't want them to know that I'm
straight cuz it's common for gay men to
do it are you more comfy having a dude
do it or a lady do it doesn't matter I
just don't want them to think I'm a
straight guy doing it I got to go be
like hey girl what's wrong with this tra
got just that's really good it's been a
long time before I got my booty ho so
clean and they're going to be like
you're straight dude they know yeah they
see you're that butthole once dude they
know that thing straight I just do the
whole like bend over with the this go oh
you know the other day my boyfriend was
[__] me so hard and he said that's
gay oh boy you got to clean your butt
hole and the waxers going to be like no
gay guys ever talk like that they hey
Real Talk Joe could pass for gay thank
you thank you this reminds me w a
straight guy a couple years before
coming out told me how much he loves
[__] and I was like oh you're gay dude
I've never heard a straight guy talk
about how much years before coming out I
like a [__] so [__] so good it's like
n9th grade pussy's the best they say
things like that nobody says that when
you're yeah yuck
[__] that I'm so straight right was he
like when I was sucking at rock hard
[__] I was like oh my God it's like
going down my throat and [__] I love
that [__] he was trying to like I don't
know be a guy around me and I was like
you're gay dude
it's and then later he came out yeah
later he came out so you called it damn
I called it it but going back to the
whole but hole thing is like I don't
even think nowadays getting your ble
eaten is like kind of normal no it's
cool that's
cool but back in the day you were you
were gross when you I don't think Bart
agrees I'm just shy it's not me you're
married want to do it I don't I'm shy
like if anything gets too close back
there I get like a what is the word like
not squeamish but like like embarrassed
like I in the pull you pull away yeah
like I like [__] like when you hide a
scar of octopus in the ocean it just
goes he's a virgin but he is curious
he's brought it up like two or three
times on his channel he's curious he's
curious about the prostate oh yeah I'm
not curious in a way where I want to
feel it I just want someone to describe
it to me so I oh he's intellectually
curious about the prostate what if you
went like for science what if you went
on your own with like a butt plug he did
it with his finger halfway before but he
claims that it's cleaning in the shower
I didn't go that deep you said halfway
he says he goes knuckle deep to clean
out his butthole in the shower second
knuckle yeah I was going to say first
knuckle if he got a little no I think
it's knuckle that's still pretty deep
that's still pretty deep that's like
deep dude inch and a half maybe you got
big old but it's really clean though n
he's got calluses
on first Knuckles sus second Knuckles
gay but I think prostate you need the
third one to touch no I don't know how'
you know did you Google that yeah how
did you know Mr int well cuz if I'm
already in the second knuckle and I've
been poking around how deep my butthole
second knuckle is like submarine looker
outer thing Periscope yeah Periscope you
can [__] my B's clean I believe you
I've never really played with a butt
plug but you've seen some of those
things and they're pretty thick like
they're thicker than that that just
crazy you should get one with a tail on
it that'd be cool oh those are cool
those are kind of cool bro cuz then you
turn into Super Mario when he flies yeah
you got the little raccoon tail out
Mario 3 yeah that's fire it's more of a
saf feature yeah well for sure a little
yeah you swallow that thing up you don't
want to swallow that thing up you're
going straight to to the doctor I was
really convinced that you shaved your
leg as a bit to I know I thought about
it and that alone would have gotten my
vote that would have been so cool
everything here is democratic I think
you should get T I would have done the
marker thing I'm like you nerd bro I
never had a tat if you get the tat I
know you're man I I vot to I feel edgy
now dude I feel different people look at
it was their first tattoo I know I was
in bed watching bro cheering you too
long what you really think about us
though when we got it like honestly I
thought that was cool really you didn't
think guys like guys are [__] because
I do I'm such a [__] that I respect
people that are like [__] I do tough
[__] oh you know but like that's like I
don't know I mean G I got gayed earrings
that make me
tough I think that hurts more than
tattoo I'm not scared of the pain I'm
scared of like not liking it yeah so you
Bart hating me next year and now I we
got the same matching tag on brand for
him that's literally happened the first
time I know that scares me more than
like Laser Technology is very good would
you get this covered up dude it's true
and you wear pants if they kick me out
of careful boys I'll just get it covered
up that's true or I might leave it yeah
the pain isn't the pain isn't it it's
like artistic
autistic liking it or not falling out
and make a YF JK video and then you
could have a laser session yeah yeah
that's also a sponsorship for your
video good content and you be like use
my promo code that is true make sure to
make it at least 10 minutes so you get
the ad break too y you two don't care
about us no more man hey you got to you
got to work dude you oh I don't think
it's 10 minutes anymore I think it's
like less no no but you can get two oh
you get two yeah yeah yeah you you're
making a wildf JK video hot tip out
there make sure it's like at least 10
minutes but honestly when I got this
tattoo at first I was nervous I was like
[__] what if I don't like it whatever
but then once you get the tattoo you
realize like oh it doesn't matter it
becomes a part of you it doesn't [__]
matter do you guys ever look down on
your I Can Go Bart oh yeah wait no
that's me yeah not even that's me now I
don't associate this a Bart at all dude
this is this is this is everybody thing
if I had on my left I'd be like this is
Bart and his ex- best friend yeah this
is morph when there's five other guys
getting it and now six potentially then
I don't know dude I think it's a little
different that's a lot again if you get
it dude are you going to get more you're
going to get more now I kind of want to
yeah see that's what I'm afraid of too
that like I get one and then I'm going
to walk in I'm going to be you because
it costs the grip it like all the
artists that you like cost the grip yeah
yeah the arti you like cost [__] tons so
like this bottom here this is like I
don't know maybe like 10 years ago this
was probably like 2,800 what the [__] so
they're not if you get go with the good
artist it's not cheap but go with me
I'll do how much was your whole arm so
far this everything well this is like 15
years old but like the whole
thing I don't know maybe like five six
grand that's my story I was I was with
Barton Gio this is like hookup too but
then it's just the amount of sessions I
think I'm at 5 grand too yeah there just
the amount of sessions you have to go
you guys got cheated 70
bucks
free talk to him tattoo is one of those
things where it looks like what you paid
for yeah yeah yeah that's why it's good
like not to get when you're 18 so I was
going to get one I was 18 I keep pushing
it off I was going to get one big when I
was like 27 28 I was literally plan it
with them with and the artist and then
like I I uh made an offer on on my house
they took it so my down payment went
there cuz yeah it would have been like a
whole sleeve no 10 grand because I
forgot about this one yeah that you have
a lot of ink and a lot of detail ta this
guy's going to cost a lot he's got a lot
of real estate I was going to do my
cakes first what well I heard in I heard
in like tattoo culture it's not cool
actually you're a bum dude I heard it's
not cool to do uh visual things first
that if you're about the culture you're
doing hidden [__] first n [__] that's
[__] cuz I was a tattoo artist
really I heard that's in the culture
what does that mean like they don't love
all the kids not you guys but they don't
love all the kids coming out and their
first tap ever's on their hand to prove
they're tough oh like you have to earn
it that that you build out oh no yeah
but we don't think we're tough this
means like we're [__] as hell yeah it
does that's why I said not really you
guys scared everybody that's kind of
tough I think I think that was more
prevalent like earlier but now that um
the taboo of like it's changed there's a
lot of [__] having tattoos now that's
what I mean I mean like the OG's kind of
that way tattoos don't hurt anymore
because the OG machines they [__]
hurt speak for yourself dude that [__]
hurt you went numbing cream no I should
have I I would have if they had it
really yeah I'm [__] 40 years old I
don't want to feel pain dude when they
first put it on I was like oh this kind
of hurts I was like oh this hurts and
then the shin didn't hurt that bad but
the muscle hurt a lot yeah and then air
of your body right depends so much
that's why you do like a quad first or
something probably won't hurt sounds
like it hurt me quad I feel like quad
wouldn't at all well not when you got
[__] iron quads like you dude why you
going to get your butt tatted dude I
just feel that was kind of tough you got
trans it's [__] weird AR that's the
opposite of that whole gay thing I'm not
saying like wow pussy's wet I love it
think about it like this you're going to
yeah but this is already this has been
like a little [__] on in my life for
the last month it's like itching and
[__] sucks oh yeah Itchy Butt itchy
butt's not good you have mosquito they t
on my mosquito bites so you're not ping
bro you got a [__] put cream on that
[__] bro but it does itch for a while
though anytime any part that has a big
clump of ink it'll itch for the rest of
its life would you guys do it oh great
so so imagine imagine your butt doing
this dude [__] that itchy cakes no a
tattoo but hole would be crazy with like
the Batista Sun you know Batista sun he
has on his belly button but on your
brown eye [__] that that' be wild I'm an
artist I just let it flow yeah I got you
you
understand good I don't like like
tattoos
anymore too many [__] ass people wear
them so that's what I do kind of like
I'm 35 and I'll bet you I'm in the top
percentile that doesn't have a tattoo be
discriminated against n dude so many
like way more so many people don't have
tattoos I feel like all my homies have
them yeah but that's because the culture
and the lifestyle you live in lot of
artists and [__] but a lot of people do
have them and it's not um I felt like it
lost its like cool Edge now yes cuz
grandmas are getting them now and saying
you got I always wanted one every
generation got that though remember how
the [__] Stamp was huge in our earlier
generation now all these [__] still
walking around with tra stamps but you
know they don't [__] like it yeah I
don't like their tra stamps I can tell
from a tattoo when they got it and why
they got it and that is what makes me
feel about
them what what does that mean what do
you feel about me dude why' you point at
me for example let's say I see a
50-year-old dude with his family and
he's like sleeves and I look I'm like oh
that's the style of today he got it
yesterday this guy had a midlife crisis
he needs to look hard that's why they
got it but if if you see a 60-year-old
Asian grandpa with the little cartoon
Eagle on the shoulder you know he killed
20 people and it could be [__] up like
his homie did it you're like oh that
guy's a [__] killer yep you know and
then it's always the so we like Killers
I'm no that is cool [__] cool
murderer cool I look at the tattoo and I
can know how I feel what about the
people who know tattoos what do you feel
what the [__] did you I'm like that's
awesome oh what about the dudes that got
two [__] shins going I everywhere
what about this bro how do you feel when
you see this guy I'm like that is
careful boys right there you know when I
walk down the street and I'm walking my
dogs and I'm wearing shorts and I'm like
damn I probably look like a such an
[__] what just with this this Shin
tattoo I don't know why I just feel like
that you think that's true we should all
go to Japan and get people's reactions
with all of us going like this all go to
Japan in 2 weeks and I was packing last
night right I was up until like 2: a.m.
packing last night and and it's hot it's
hot as hell everywhere I'm going and I
was like [__] I'm bringing pants yeah
for real yeah you going to cover up why
don't you just get a big band-aid and
you can just put it over the the front
why you going to cover it up can at
least wear shorts for one of the days so
you can tell us what happened I'm going
to bring pants and I'm going to [__]
cut off the right leg how crazy is that
that uh old school Tech culture there
cuz before you had to cover up right
yeah well now now now there's tattoo
parlers everywhere and Hell people got
tattoos but you still can't go to the
onson the uh cuz the old people they
still have trauma yeah yeah we were last
time we went to a smaller town and then
Bart and our other buddies we were all
they were like in tank tops and then
they were all showing tats when they
walked down the street all the old
people just went and they they moved to
the side and let them pass it's just
gang [__] this [__] does look
like gangster I look nice you do no
nobody moves aside from me I don't even
have that style I have theive style old
people walk by
[__] you know and [__] cuz back then
there used to be hella like gang rumbles
and stuff like that right so when the
mob was ready to go to war they took off
their suits and then they walked around
with their tats exposed and then that's
when everyone's like oh [__] something's
going to go down so then when these guys
walked around with tank tops it
just those grandpas and grandmas have
old memories of people being stabbed in
the street you know I mean same here
like my family was telling me about
Cleveland and stuff like you guys seen
the movie the Irishman yeah yeah it's
too long so old so that's that's tapped
into my family my uncle's like a
character in that [__] his car got blown
up
his wait your uncle's a character and
you won't watch the movie I know I just
found out because it's all it's like
real mob [__] you getting wax I'm the
youngest cousin yeah I swear so no one
told me stuff I thought my family I knew
we were Italian and Irish and all this I
thought you're Argentinian that's Mom
side okay yeah uh so dad's side yeah
they're all in that they all had West
117th where they grew up tatted on them
everyone like above my dad's J see you
see that Generation all they need is
text and is scary as [__] these days
people [__] tattoo their eyes and
[__] and I'm like you're a loser put
horns oh yeah that stuff freaks me out
they used to be on like TL or whatever
TV show I to turn off yeah yeah I'm out
I'm out yeah but these days when you see
a young [__] boy with tattoos all over
their face and neck you're like dude
you're weak I'm like you're an island
boy yeah all those rappers are like 5T
tall but they got like millions of
dollars they're hell big influencers I
know and they're way cooler than us yeah
they're way cooler than us they may go
out with each other for money though and
I respect that they're really good at
kissing dude they're really good they're
good at something I'm jealous kissing
each other is crazy crazy your twin
that's that's nuts it's crazy other
twins weren't doing it earlier they were
first Movers dude imagine the Olsen
twins oh dude where are they now they
need that o money now bro they're
blowing up they would make a billion
dollar I'm subscribing that's my first
of subscribe are they still hot it's all
Elizabeth now though Marvel movies huh
yeah she's the she related to him yeah
it's Olen yeah what about Olen homes I'm
a fan of their developments this is the
end of the
[Music]
video